السبب ان دخلت كمال اجسام دراغون بول احب
الانمي شفته معضل صرت زيها
معكم عبد الله وائل الربيعه معروف ربيعه
عمري تقريبا الحين 32 سنه
بديت كمان اجسام من 2005 حاليا اتوقع
تي عانيت عمري 15 سنه صغير طفران ويبيض
الين خلاص يا رجال خليك تشترك في النادي
الله يجزاك خير هم ما كان يدرون على اي
شيء ابدا بس يعرفون واحد معضل
شيل الاسمنت اي شيء موجود شله لكن حاليا
لا اكيد يعرفون
الحين امي تشوف تقول هذا مو بناشف هذا
[موسيقى]
مبنيه على اراء تحكيميه عندك خمس دقايق او
دقيقه او عشر دقايق اللي هو محطوط لك هذه
في حقه تجهيزك كامل لانك تنزل صح
لانك تجيب العيد في واحد لا والله يعرف
زين في واحد يطلع عضلات بشكل حلو في واحد
لا يعني عنده نقاط قوه بس ما اعرف يعرض
يعني العرض يبيله تدريب عليه راي مني انا
والحكام من الافضل وتقييم الافضل هذا يقيس
على النشافه على حق الجسم يعني شكل الجسم
هيئته وتقبل الراي لازم تكبر لانك انت
رايح تلعب خلاص تكبر الرايه ما تبي تلعب
لا تلعب روح بيتكم مشخص في استراحه يا
حبيبي عش حياتك
[موسيقى]
شخص طبيعي ترى زيه زيك معي ترى ممكن يصير
بعد اغبى منك يعني مع الاسف يعني عادي
تلاقيه يحب انمي
انا احب الانمي في الفتره يمكن قبل ثلاث
سنوات انهم يتميلحون وانهم يدورون الشوق
منهم انهم كذا حاليا بطولات
[موسيقى]
يسوون صبغه الجسم اول شيء توحد اللون اوكي
مع اللايت والاضاءه توحد اللون بين
الاشخاص معي الشيء الثاني تبين تقاسيم
الجسم الشيء الثالث عشان تكون العذراء
بارزه بشكل اكبر فقط رغي لانها عشان كذا
هم يحطون الصبغه طبعا اسبوعين كامل تتروش
عشان تروح ولا تروح اي زي التان تقريبا
ايه
[موسيقى]
اوه يا كثرهم
من هالناحين والله ليش المعضلين خلنا نذكر
فيهم عيب انهم هذا الشيء عيب والحمد لله
ما اشوف اشياء كثير ناس اعرفهم انا عندي
بنت واخويا عندهم ما شاء الله عيال
مسترزقين الله وماشي امورهم معضلين
وعايشين حياتهم ولا في هذا الكلام اللي
يقولونه بالعكس اذا كنت رياضي تزيد انت
قطر الجنسيه
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء
[موسيقى]
قدر النعمه اللي قدام مهما كانت حبه الرز
ذي والله انه يقدرها حبه الرز الصغيره هذه
الناس الله يهديهم يصلحهم يرمونها والله
العظيم انها شيء خرافي فهمتي يعني اخذها
من الاضواء كلها لان صدق صدق نعمه ما ترمي
يعني انا لاني اجوع فتره طويله حسيت
بالناس اللي ما عندهم الحمد لله رب
العالمين عندي هلا كل هذا كله التزمت
لدرجه انها طلعت عيوني وعرفت انه ما راح
احقق الله سبحانه وتعالى لك شيء اذا
التزمت مئه بالمئه فيه حبيب قلبي
واحده منهم فان شاء الله نقول ان شاء الله
الحلقه
اذا ما فزت
حبيب قلبي كذا
[موسيقى]
واحده واحده